c'est dans quelques jours aura lieu
l'élection de miss france comme vous le
savez elles doivent tout répondre en
direct un test afin de tout répondent
tout répondre à un test de culture
générale
andreas est allé dans la rue interroger
les françaises sur ces questions de
culture générale
ben vous allez voir c'est pas hyper
facile d'être miss et les vraies
questions des miss regarde dans peu de
temps il y aura l'élection des miss
france
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut être
intelligent pour être miss faudrait mais
c'est pas ce qui ressort à l'image
qu'elles ont l'air intelligent pas tout
du coup il ya le test de culture
générale des missions ce qui est tombée
je suis en bac + 3 donc si c'est pas
répondre qu'est-ce qu'on célèbre en
france mais on sait qu est-ce qu on
célèbre en france le 11 novembre le
black friday le premier ministre
français et manuel valls et manuel valls
oui oui ok c'était d'orchidées à tanger
de l'est là le grand là le l'on attend
sinon si c'était ça en dit long
quelle est la première personne
singulière duverne appelé au présent de
l'indicatif comment je m'appelle
j'appelle de quel pays bachar al assad
et si le président ça commence par un
ace c'est la série c'est pas la
prestation du coup de filet mission pas
si bête que ça
ah non pas maintenant tout cas
mouais merci en voilà c'est passé son
sapin
[Applaudissements]